a lawyer for a person of interest in the
case of four men missing in Pennsylvania
says his client confessed to killing
them 20 year-old Cosmo DiNardo said I'm
sorry yesterday as he left the
courthouse
searchers discovered Dean Finocchiaro s
body Wednesday from a common grave Jim
Patrick Tom mio and mark Sturgis have
not yet been identified
DeMarco Morgan is at the Bucks County
Courthouse in Doylestown Pennsylvania
DeMarco good morning good morning just
one day after authorities uncovered a 12
and a half foot deep common grave on the
Donato family property Cosmo Donato
confessed to the killings but they are
still a number of unanswered questions
this morning how did he kill the victims
why did he kill the victims and did he
act alone was all Cosmo DiNardo said to
reporters as he was led away in
handcuffs
Paul lang one of Gennaro's defense
attorney said his client was much more
forthcoming with prosecutors
he confessed to his participation or
commission in the murders of the four
young men in exchange for that
confession mr. DiNardo was promised by
the district attorney that he will spare
his life by not invoking the death
penalty an anonymous source with
first-hand knowledge of the confession
told The Associated Press turn Ardell
sold marijuana to the victim but he felt
cheated or threatened during the
transactions the source said the men
were killed as separately and a
co-conspirator was involved in three of
the killings I can't answer them text
messages obtained by CBS this morning
show DiNardo had been part of a group
chat set up by friends of the missing
men when asked if he was worried about
his buddy dean Finocchiaro DiNardo
called him a pill-popping junkie who
probably just jumped parole those
messages as well as these snapchat
photos of DiNardo posing with a revolver
were first reported by philly.com bucks
county district attorney Matthew Juan
draw I know more than I'm sharing on the
relationships and I have to keep it that
way on Facebook for no geo rules on Tina
wrote I am completely crushed
heartbroken and numb
dangle Bob Buena worked with her no gr
oh I'm gonna miss him you know I feel
bad I just want to be strong for him
because he wants a strong kid you know
CBS News has learned from a source it
was a signal from a cell phone that
originally led them to the Genaro family
farm there and of course they are still
working to identify the remains in the
grave at this hour
bianna the tragedy for that community to
Marco thank you